The Joe Rogan experience, is it? Oh,
this is what I was going to say. Yeah.
We were talking about, uh, uh, we
weren't even talking about this, but
my daughter is watching
these youtube videos of this.
There's this young gay fellow does
makeup tutorials Charles. Oh yeah.
Okay. He's enormous. Ease, enormous.
You know, he, he,
he probably gets more views than any
network show that's ever been created.
How old was this fellow? He's young. He's
like 20. Oh, okay. What do you say, Jan?
I'm trying to lie if I
should bring this out here.
I just put the last thing that
popped in my head during Coachella,
he got accused of being in this viral
video that happened. It wasn't him,
but there's the Ferris wheel Coachella.
No.
Have you ever seen that
dude I'm talking about? No.
It's a big famous thing that people
take pictures in front of. Uh,
during a concert you could
see a silhouette of somebody
getting head in there
and it's two guys. Oh, really? It's
a very vivid video that was going on,
went super viral on Twitter that night,
and they were saying it was him. Yeah.
How dare they. He's all about makeup,
not ahead. Yeah. Sons of bitches.
Keep it to reapply your lipstick and
keep it clean, but it's hilarious.
My, my sister, Oh, me and my sister.
My daughter sits in front of
the TV cackling watching. It is,
it is supposed to be funny.
She thinks it's funny. Yeah.
She thinks he's hilarious for
laughter. I don't know. Yeah.
I mean he's covered in crazy makeup.
I think what she was laughing at though,
in all fairness was he was making
fun of someone subscriber 6 million,
16 million black.
I think he was making fun of people
that put on too much makeup. Okay,
so he was going crazy with them.
Yeah. She thought it was really funny.
That is fucking banana. 16 million
people and he's doing makeup tutorials.
He looks great. He looks great.
That's the thing. It's like we,
there's an always on Kardashian,
right.
Kinds of shit like this that you
would have never expected. Yeah,
and because of the access,
because on demand access,
especially like through computer,
it's so easy.
It's so easy to just type in
the next thing. John Reed.
What's next? Just pops up.
Yeah, so like these people that
no network in their right mind,
like NBC would never
say, Hey, that young guy,
let's get that guy to do a makeup show.
They'd be like,
get the fuck out of the office. You
don't know shit about ratings. Meanwhile,
8 billion subscribers. That's crazy.
That'd be a fun game to play is like,
what rabbit hole would youtube
send you down if you typed in this?
I just let it keep going.
That's up on its own.